you are listening to the hot breath
podcast I am your host comedian Joel
Byers and welcome to your weekly guide
to comedy mastery with Tamra go in Tamra
Goins welcome to hot breath thank you
for doing this we're sitting oh thanks
you're the head of comedy and innovative
artists a long way from wrapping with
too short back in the day
what was your rap name entice whoa you
rapper too short of 15 Wow so you've
always had you've always been making
moves in your life I guess who's been a
power player so as the head of comedy
here at innovative artists what it what
exactly does that mean what is your job
description all right it means that I
oversee a department that has a an agent
in every area to represent a comedians
life so we have an unscripted agent we
have a scripted agent we have touring
agents we have voiceover we have and
then television and film so I have one
person that I only think she does a
television and film for our comedians
only so the people that don't
necessarily have acting credits they
don't get left behind or loss impacts
and you were an agent at one time right
are you still you're still an agent I
was like comedy and then I was an agent
at resolution which was Jeff Berg
formerly the CEO of ICM was his startup
so a lot of the a lot of people
interview on here are more on the show
side of show business but you're on the
business side right at a very high level
and there's comedians can be good at the
show but not the business side or
convenes can be good at the business
side and not the show side so what are
some common mistakes you're seeing
comedians that maybe aren't making it
what are the
some of mistakes you're seeing I mean
well I think that the the reason why
agents and managers have jobs is because
the talent would prefer to be creative
and that's the the thing that they're
strong that if they were good at
everything all around they wouldn't
really need us and there are some that
you know can balance but it is a huge
undertaking and if you have to focus on
the business it does take away from the
creative however you should still know
and be in tune with the business side of
things I think one of the biggest things
is getting your loan out or your
corporation set up know I had one one
client who he did a project for vh1 and
it was like 10 episodes only to get his
check and it was half of what he
expected because of the taxes that they
take out in California now had he had
his loan out together then they wouldn't
take anything out and you're responsible
to pay your own taxes and you know in
that way you can write off all of the
expenses that it takes to be who you are
mmm so in that case you know he had made
enough money that he said okay we'll
leave that there and not get the cheque
recut but it was it was significant and
it was a huge lesson for how to get
incorporated I guess like your LLC and
all in that chance well this is your
first podcast so I know
okay breath exclusive so you good so the
interesting thing about the LLC is that
something has happened within the last
year that payroll companies are not
accepting the LLC so now we are having
to have our clients change the LLC into
an S corp for it to be valid because
otherwise they're saying that they have
to be they have to cut the check to them
as an individual and now you're back to
the problem of them taking out the taxes
so we went really far right there right
even like just for people oh it's so
easy to get impatient especially in
comedy right now and you see someone go
viral and it seems like overnight
their success which I mean you know you
know the kind of people have built
careers on the Internet
we're sure but how does how does a
comedian know when they're even ready to
be like okay I need I need an agent now
it's time to take the next level you
know I mean I've had people come up to
me at comedy clubs and say I need agent
and I'm like why because I want to know
why you think you need an agent a lot of
times people they think that an agent
relationship is very transactional a
manager's relationship is more strategy
hmm and you know and laying out what
that plan is and and gathering all of
the assets like if you have a reel so
even if you're doing a lot of stuff just
aren't on your own you know with the
videos piecing something together where
you can you can you can see your acting
ability because if you have someone that
you know they're like oh I want to use
this person and they're like do they
have a reel and if we say no then I'm
scrambling around trying to find
something I don't care if it's an
independent film or if it's you know a
sketch but those assets are so important
to the transaction of it all otherwise I
have to stop what I'm doing and go put
on a manager hat and and find these
things that it takes to sell the person
what are some of the other assets so it
would be any PK electronic press kit you
know it's like okay what can I send out
in one email that tells this casting
director who you are you know instead of
you know it being an email stream you
know do you have a reel do you have
their standup do they have headshots
do they have new headshots you know you
know it's like their resume there's all
of these things that you know you may
think are archaic but they're still used
in the tradition in traditional
Hollywood so being on break down
you know just having all your all my
stuff being listed in IMDB having an
IMDB Pro account depending on what your
goals are now if you just want to do if
you just want to do touring then you
hustle shows but if you're truly in the
business of or your goals are to act and
compete with actors then you have to do
what actors do and you know outside of
taking acting classes which I you know
really recommend it's even if you get
the opportunity have the rest of your
business set up and in terms of
followers that's almost like a currency
it seems like now in comedy that
followers can almost create leverage but
from the business side how important and
relevant are act followers on social
media I mean it depends on what the goal
is for the show so if you're talking
about television and migrating eyeballs
to something that's free that's what
influencers do mm-hmm you know it's like
there's a lot of free content and they
have people that can watch their stuff
for free so in terms of migrating that
those eyeballs and creating that
interaction it can be looked at as
marketing so but they still want you to
have a level of talent and you know
efficiency so I mean but even with that
it's almost like you know here's the
money for his acting and but here's the
money for the marketing piece of this
and the expectation of what the
marketing is you know once it comes out
because before they just assume that the
person would you know promote but
there's there's cachet and promoting so
you know that's where that that peace
comes in but now that they're finding
that even if you have a lot of followers
what's that engagement so if your
engagement is low then now I'm now the
networks are catching they're catching
on then it's not just about how many
followers it's you know what that
engagement is per post when you're
posting something that's about the
influencer personally as opposed
to posting something that has nothing to
do with them like for sponsorship like
if you know that this person doesn't
drink and then they post because you're
you know the followers they know who you
are
yeah if you don't drink and now you put
posting alcohol ad you're not
necessarily gonna get the engagement
because your followers know is not
authentic yeah that's shining through
more than ever and people are starting
to get called out on that is moving to
LA still as necessary as that once was
with the internet and that awareness
well I think that there are things that
happen here they can't happen anywhere
and that's bumping into jet Apatow at a
you know comedy club more you know
bumping into you know an executive or an
executives coming out to a comedy club
or even just having a casting director
that's working on one thing that you go
in that you may not be right for but now
they'll remember if you're memorable
then they'll think about you for the
next casting job that they have cuz
that's not a one-off for them you know
so the more that you're you know being
here it's there's just more opportunity
for relationships and networking to
happen that doesn't necessarily happen
if you live in you know Alabama yeah and
and I live in Atlanta and you know I've
been I've been under this I don't know
if it's a delusion or what that at this
point it's like I just want to get
really good at comedy and then let that
be the driving force behind the
opportunities I get
right so since I started I was like I
want to do it from Atlanta but is do you
have reality for me or do you think I
mean certainly has their produce I mean
doing a lot of the productions are in
Atlanta but a lot of the decisions are
still made from here mm-hmm
so in terms of lead roles and in terms
of you know even like the directors are
all like really the top level pieces of
the puzzle they're still cast here and
then the bow
some things so it's not impossible but
you still have to network and know who's
doing what and be involved but a lot of
that a lot of the information and the
decisions are still being driven from
here unless it's you know like will will
Packer or you know something that is
understands and is you know is based
there himself you know that his
production may find you know start from
Atlanta but a lot of the other people
they're still you know pretty
traditional in the flow of information
and a co people that you work with like
DC young fly and like a manual Hudson
both from Atlanta was that more like an
internet thing you found them on I mean
well it was one out so I was from well
yeah okay the thing for the guys that
are you know self-made if you will where
I can help is to navigate through
Hollywood in a way that you know
something I mean a lot they're they're
they're roads have been unconventional
in terms of you know Hollywood standard
but there's still things and you know in
the traditional sense that you need to
know there's still protocol and there's
information that you won't have unless
you're in the mix so I think that what I
found that the power of the agency is
the information you know it's to know
that if you're if I'm uh if I'm if I
have an independent agency and I'm
negotiating for someone I only know what
I have so all I have to go with is their
initial offer however if I'm in an
agency and previously I've dealt with
these people and I know that they paid
somebody else more then they can't tell
me you know that that's all they have
because I know and so that really is the
power of the agency I think what should
comedians be looking for in an agent or
any red flags
you know I think I mean for me because I
was a buyer first when I produced Shaq
all-star mmm-hmm I dealt with agents and
so my experience with the big guys that
you know most of you know the people
that were on Shaq all-star is that they
wouldn't tell the truth or they would
you know use one you know one person's
offer to leverage another person's offer
when they're two separate people or they
would lag they they know full well that
they weren't going to do it and they
wouldn't give me the courtesy of telling
me that it was a pass you know just just
you know just really being underhanded
or if something went wrong being
cowardly and not being able to say
something went wrong to allow the buyer
to have time to recover because it's
show business right thing things change
all the time and so that's the constant
is change but when you're when you don't
have the information to recover it puts
you in a bad situation
so everything that really perturbed me
about agents I don't do you know it's
like I try to get I don't you know I
don't avoid calls so there's not gonna
be a time when somebody calls my office
and I keep saying
tell me call back telling the car I'm
not putting my assistant in that
situation I take the call and let's
resolve it and so I can get it off my
desk and that they're not if it's no
it's no you know so I think you know
making sure that the agents not blowing
smoke hmm that they're really you know
if they can't do so I would prefer for
work you know I prefer for someone to
tell you the truth so you know how to
recover from that
then for somebody to say oh no it's
gonna be you know just you know give it
two months you'll be living in LA you'll
be you know all that and you're
preparing for something that may not be
your truth so I would say look for
somebody that can tell you the good and
the bad and you know isn't afraid to
give you the criticism that you need to
grow and on the management side I guess
it's only agents here at innovative so
the manager they're more of like you
said the strategy because this is a
world I'm unfamiliar with I'm unwrapped
and just been doing everything
independently so the manager what are
the kind of skill
they would bring to the table I mean
they would lay out the strategy for you
and say okay what are the projects that
you have what are your goals and then
let's map out how you get there and then
they use the agency to put that you know
to make those things come true whether
that's calls or meetings and Matt
there's a lot there's some definitely
some overlap especially in the beginning
of somebody doesn't have an agent and
then in my case I have some guys that
have been in the business a long time
they don't have managers so then I end
up as a hybrid which because I've been
on the other side of the business I can
do but it's time-consuming so in a
perfect world you have some a manager
that is working hand in hand with you
and you know so I don't have to stop and
go find the assets that I need to show
that this person is amazing mm-hmm you
know but the but then managers to
managers can produce so they can be
partners with the client in terms of you
know putting likes a sitcom together
agents can't agents can only Commission
and it's a like I said a real
transactional relationship mm-hmm so
managers aren't supposed to book there's
so there's like you know there's like
rules to it really that a lot of people
outside of LA don't adhere to out of
necessity more so out of you know just
hustling what you get but once you get
here there's an etiquette you know that
it's nice if it's followed and more
embraced and nobody knows what's
embraced in comedy more than you with
your experience and the people you've
been around you've you work with the
like 1% of comedy so being around these
exclusively like high-performing high
achieving people what are some of the
common traits you're seeing with these
people it's not sleeping it's not it's
self investing you know it's not chasing
pennies missing dollars you know self
investing self investing making sure
that you know you have that you
you a photo shooting that you have your
headshots making sure that if you don't
have a website that even your Facebook
page has all the information you know if
I if you making sure that doing your own
Flyers even if someone's booked at a
club the clubs have 52 weeks to promote
they're not gonna promote you outside of
the website until the Monday before the
show so if you want to have if you don't
have social media then you need to
create your own marketing plan and and
whatever they're doing consider
ancillary so what you're doing to
promote yourself any other common traits
or really I know where we're gonna land
this plane here so really in just in
summing it up any other in advice
insights you could share to the
listeners from your perspective in the
comedy world you know I have people that
come and say I'm funnier than anybody
out there and it's not enough to just be
funny very much the same way that it's
not enough for your wife or your
girlfriend to just be cute you know it's
like you know is she a good cook is she
clean is she smart you can't you know
what are her ideas about finances it's
very much the same way what kind of
partner are you in turn as a as a client
as an artist
are you a marketing partner are you you
know it's you know so it's funny but are
you on time you know are you you know do
you double-booked yourself do you not
show up you know so there's more things
to just being funny so I would just say
don't let that be the thing that you
hang your hat on you know you have to
bring the business to it you show up but
it's it is show business boom heard it
from the best right here
Tamra Goins you pointed my point at them
let them know the camera thanks for
doing this you you hadn't done anything
like this was you're honored
oh my gosh you're gonna make me blush
alright well Tamra Goins thinks beyond
hot breath yeah that was
[Music]
I breath